the execution was pretty high on our
side
especially from the second quarter on
defense gave us some
uh shorter fields in the second quarter
we cashed them in obviously a big
interception by job was important and
then hitting the
marquez like going in half really kind
of turned
turned the tide i think a little bit for
us put us up by a couple scores
that was obviously very important for us
um but just a different atmosphere like
i said you know this is a really tough
place to play with the noise
as is lambo so it's going to be you know
strange next week to not hear our fans
either
and there is a fine line between
effective video conferencing and hostage
video i was trying to pick up what aaron
rodgers was really trying to tell us
about his captors
what in the world was that chris hello
yes hello well he's you know the outlaw
he's back baby he just he just threw
your damn team in jail and said yeah
you'll stay there for a while
okay i'm sorry right now sorry and um
i think he was a little motivated yeah
he should be happier
he made no reference to going home and
having a scotch or sipping tequila
he was incredible yesterday what was
that well maybe he drank so much tequila
ever since they drafted jordan love he's
had a spill for the year so he's just
got to get back to
the drawing board he's he's ready for
football now he's going sober all out
but
man he was unbelievable yesterday
i mean he really was almost every throw
i know it was probably making you sick
watching him dice and around and
throwing lasers
whoa oh aaron rodgers
listen i'm an adult i'm a professional
yeah and i'm trying to watch nine games
at once yeah when the viking game
stinks it's all the more easier for me
to focus on the other games and i could
tell from the very beginning the first
drive
the way aaron rodgers went down the
field it was gonna be a long day so
anyway we saved aaron rodgers until this
hour because we start the second hour
with our superlatives
from week one the first sunday of the
regular season and i specifically
instructed matt casey our producer today
to
wait on rogers because i knew that would
be chris's superglue so we may as well
just talk about it all now
yeah we might as well oh aaron rod what
do i want to give them you know what do
we want to give them today for a
superlative the
the red hot poker award or do we want to
give them the
you know middle finger to the rest of
the nfl
i mean whatever you want it uh green bay
that offense the emergence of valdez
scantling if he can be that type of
threat
throwing the ball down the field i just
i mean green bay
that it'll change the way i look at
their football team i mean that was the
big question was who could be that other
receiver
and the way it started yesterday uh
aggressive
down the field throwing by the green bay
packers all the things we kind of want
they gotta if they want to be in the nfc
championship or maybe the super bowl
they got to be better at that they need
another weapon on offense
you know rogers needs to let it go a
little bit more and take some chances he
did all of that yesterday
and looked good moving around too so
yeah
i mean he he looked like a man on a
mission he was pretty awesome
and that's devante adams let me tell you
if he keeps playing like he did
yesterday if he keeps working if he
keeps putting in the effort he
eventually may be a top 10 wideout
you're a funny guy you really are
14 catches 156 yards and two touchdowns
for adams but valdez scantling added 96
and the ball was spread around
pretty well i mean it wasn't like the
cardinals where it was all hopkins and
then everyone
else just with bits and pieces there was
more
feasting done than just devonte adams
but yeah incredible day
for aaron rodgers 32 for 44 364.
four touchdowns a passer rating of 127.5
that's incredible for a full game to
have a passer rating that high every
once in a while we see somebody have
something higher than that but not often
no and uh rogers was great
and chris look here's what happens when
you go into a stadium where you you used
to not being able to hear yourself
think now all of a sudden you can go in
and operate your offense you know
these teams that play their home games
in loud stadiums
their their defenses aren't nearly as
good
as we would be led to believe no you saw
that yesterday you're right i mean
it's unfortunate but some of these teams
are built
because of that too hey we want a fast
front four
because we play on field turf so we want
that advantage
and then our crowd noise and uh their
ability to be loud
gives our defensive line the jump on the
snap count that's another advantage
along with the surface whoa we're
lightning fast out here
yeah that advantage is going to be taken
away from a team those teams like the
minnesota vikings where
that's a part of their their kind of
their dna as a football team
but yeah i mean if i'm minnesota i'm a
little worried about my defense in
general we saw
a lot of new pieces out there yesterday
with no daniel hunter
and the way the packers pass protected i
mean rogers could bake a cake back there
a few times
and then you know we talked about a lot
in the offices you got some new new
parts
in minnesota secondary and rogers picked
on them especially it looked like number
24 holton hill when he saw him matched
up man-to-man
they went at him so minnesota's have to
go back to the drawing board too
and get healthy and figure out what they
want to do as far as their their
approach is concerned because their
offense stunk too
i want to be positive in this segment
especially the first
monday of the year and i've got plenty
of positivity but
since we're in this neighborhood let me
go ahead and hand out the scholarship
year award to the minnesota vikings and
this gets back to something chris
that i argued back in january after the
vikings exited the postseason in ugly
fashion
against the 49ers you have multiple key
individuals
up for contract extensions entering the
final years of their deals
kirk cousins mike zimmer rick spielman
and dalvin cook and what happened that
win over the saints in the wild card
round
delivered extensions for all of them my
argument back then
was don't extend any of them force them
to go into this year
and put you in a spot where you've got
to sign them
as they're about to hit the market make
them chase that
carrot because now when you throw in
financial security with this crazy
upside
down world we're living in with no fans
it's very easy
to just say this year isn't real
next year we'll get back to work and if
yesterday's performance was an
indication of how it's going to go all
season long for the vikings
most points ever allowed by the vikings
in an opening game in their franchise
history
it's going to be a very long year yeah
it definitely is you're right and
they're kind of caught they're a team
that's kind of caught i feel like where
they're trying to kind of semi
rebuild retool on the fly going oh we
have a core here we kind of like
we think we can win with them but you
know a core is
a small group of players a team wins
championships and yeah i just don't
think the vikings are
a complete team as we sit here going
into the 2020 season or now one game in
all right i mean let him go
let him go you see what he can freaking
do when you let him go
russell wilson holy cow i mean we it's
been an hour we haven't talked about him
yet what the hell are we doing here
i mean whoa don't run the ball anymore
let him go
okay because you could see what russell
wilson can freaking do when you play
through the pass game
i mean that was amazing yesterday too i
i don't know where to start i mean you
know you know i was gushing about aaron
rodgers i think i got to gush more about
russell wilson what i saw there
i mean first off i just love how seattle
came out
attacked the atlanta falcons you know
really came out not trying to just
pound the run game in between the
tackles a few
creative screens and play action passes
and then the way he throws the football
and
again here's another guy mike i think
this might be a trend that we got to
watch out for
guys like russell wilson aaron rodgers
on the road
like you're talking about on these
surfaces
it's changed the game you know it has oh
yeah defensive line can't get a jump
okay russ
you know like like we saw here in roger
he'll sit back there and
oh yeah come on and come and get me you
might sack me oh sir here i go zoom and
then he throws a ball 30 yards by your
your ear but him dk metcalf 14 to 12
it's fourth and five and they go hmm
it's man-to-man let's throw a go route
for a 45-yard touchdown to dk metcalf
that changed the game and russell wilson
was just
absolutely phenomenal yesterday and
according to pro football
focus 68 percent passing on first and
second down for the seahawks that was
made
also against man coverage 22 for 23 was
russell wilson look
this was mandatory and and it's funny i
think i've
found a a trigger for tony dungy all i
have to do is mention the possibility of
russell wilson leaving seattle uh he has
adamantly opposed that concept but i'm
look
he's talked about it himself russell
wilson told
us russell wilson has said it more
recently
the idea that he wants a greater sense
of urgency on offense earlier in the
games and i know for a fact that that
conversation was had in very pointed
fashion
with the team in a
not quite flat out ultimatum but the
message is clear
yeah let russ cook or you're gonna as i
was told by a source close to russell
wilson or you're gonna be baking the
farewell cake and they
they heeded it they did what they had
why wouldn't you
got one of the best quarterbacks in the
entire national football league you've
got a ferrari
in your garage that you refuse to drive
above 25 miles per hour
it's an easy thing to do it's not like
that they're telling you to go take a
a jalopy 50 miles an hour down the road
you have the car
go drive it and it worked yeah and uh
and and you know
we get to see it again sunday night
against the new england patriots i know
i can't wait that's going to be
a lot of fun to watch and this will be a
different test for that seattle offense
but
yes you're paying them all that money
the way the team's formulated right now
there's probably more go-to aspects on
the offensive side of the football when
you break down yeah uh
lock it with metcalf chris carson how
good he is
hey greg olsen infused in the tight end
lineup gives them another weapon there
you know we got to see if philip dorsett
can contribute and all that too but
either way seattle's defense is good
it's not great but they don't need to be
great to get to a super bowl or even win
a super bowl they just got to be around
like the middle of the league
last year i believe they were 22nd in
football and we saw
we didn't hit on this yet either but
jamal adams is going to change that
defense for sure
well that's another thing that was very
impressive about the seattle seahawks
and the way they looked yesterday they
got difference makers
everywhere in the field and that's big
russell wilson is wired to credit
everyone on his team but there are
certain guys that he credited even more
heavily when i talked to him yesterday
when i asked him for his reactions to
maul adams
it was just one i mean it was you could
hear the shift in his voice
hall of fame championship caliber
leadership
passion i mean exactly what that defense
needs so
russell wilson's on board jamal adams
said yesterday it's you know it's
basically
fun to play for a team that can score
that many points yeah he's been stuck
with a team that can't right
shot out the door upper cut you won
you won let it go serious as you would
say but uh
the the the other thing too russell
wilson talked to me about how much time
he spent in the offseason with dk
metcalf working on helping him
elevate and he's convinced metcalf is
one of the best receivers in football
right now
underrated along with tyler lockett
russell's happy about that they're not
going to stay underrated though
if they keep throwing the ball the way
they have metcalf had a huge
how in the hell does this guy stay on
the board until the bottom of round
two chris but this is a guy who's going
to be a cornerstone of that offense with
russell wilson for years to come
yeah he's he's he's a freak of nature i
mean he he really is he's one of those
guys that you just see him and you go
he looks different than most receivers
wow i mean he's a specimen and you can
see his ability to run
and just run by people catch the ball
break tackles
they're receiving core they got a chance
they do this is i think as good as
russell's ever had around him as far as
real big time play makers
i know baldwin and that group curse were
very good
i don't know if they had the big time
play-making ability that this group does
and i think that's what excites me about
the seahawks
all right next one for me and i got i am
going to go positive how about this
revenge is a dish best served ice code
award although it doesn't sound all that
positive no it does not
avenging their last regular season
defeat
when the cleveland browns went
to town last year week four
beat the ravens that's the last time the
ravens have lost
a regular season game the browns came
back yesterday to start the season
better browns team this year who knows
what the ravens are going to be
we found out what the ravens are going
to be 38-6
blown off the field where the cleveland
browns and the ravens picking up
exactly where they left off and getting
their revenge nearly a year later for
what the browns did to them
in 2019 yeah impressive win impressive
win and
uh did it without dominating the run
game i think that's where i look at it
and go
hmm okay baltimore oh what do we need to
see from lamar jackson
the next step in pocket passing being
precise doing all those things
well we freaking saw it yesterday in
week one you know i don't know
it's the greatest receiver throwing
quarterback i've ever seen
man good thing they moved his butt to
quarterback that was a good move
holy cow because we know what he can do
athletically but yesterday
how many times when we were sitting
there watching the game did he make
unbelievable throws within the pocket
and not to just guys that were screaming
wide open because they were dominating
the run game it was play action pass now
these were true pocket passes
into tight windows sidearm touch
oh an out route to mark andrews in the
end zone tight coverage
zoo laser in there i mean lamar jackson
was
really really impressive and um they
were on
another class from cleveland yesterday
cleveland didn't even look like they
belonged on the field with them
and let's remember this and we're going
to talk more about this coming up
because i had an extended conversation
with john harbaugh the coach of the team
yesterday but this was
start number 23 in the regular season
for lamar jackson
the ceiling is still out there this
isn't a grizzled veteran who
is you know entering the back half of
his prime
his prime isn't even going to be here
for three or four more years
you know as long as he stays healthy i
know it's a little bit different for him
than patrick mahomes because so much of
his game is premised on running the
football but my god chris
to see where lamar jackson is to see the
growth
in the passing game already that bodes
very well for the ravens and not so well
for their opponents
over the next five or ten years no i
mean if he can get to that point where
you start to go
oh man he's a deadly passer he can throw
with precision
accuracy and he understands our
defensive pass
coverages and knows where to go with the
ball every time
and we're seeing he's gotten remarkably
better each year so far
yeah they'll be unstoppable because
they're big as hell up front they got
unbelievable running backs and they got
some scary receivers and tight ends that
can scare you
you know in the past game so yeah
baltimore lamar jackson
harbaugh it's that's uh quite the group
there and and growth was the word that
harbaugh used because he's seen it from
lamar jackson throughout camp he saw it
yesterday he said he played his belt
about as well as he could have played
which means you know maybe he is getting
close to the ceiling but i think once he
gets to the ceiling he's going to bust
through it and find an even higher level
of performance
the decision-making the patience
everything about the way
he controls that offense and grows into
that offense and
you know we we talked about the
importance
of forgetting about last year
because that's what bill belichick would
do with the patriots forget about last
year last year's over
harbaugh told me that his guys keenly
remember last year because that's their
standard
they remember 14 and two and it's risky
because if you lose a game or two early
on all of a sudden you can't match 14
and two you better come up with some
other standard
but for them they know what they did
last year and that
is their bar for this year that's their
minimum for this year
and when you see that kind of a blowout
win right out of the gates i mean that
that's the kind of team that has the
potential
to have that special season we saw it
from the chiefs the other night
look at the chief's home schedule i mean
they are going to roll and the ravens
are going to roll and oh by the way
it's just two weeks from tonight the
ravens and the chiefs cross
paths on monday night football so so one
of these two potentially dominant teams
is going to lose barring a tie before
too long but
you know lamar jackson um it was not
a one-year fluke this guy is laying the
foundation to be one of the great nfl
quarterbacks for years to come
and uh uh you know the we we talked
about mahomes
we talked about kyla murray you know
kyle murray is the only one of them that
was the first overall pick who's having
this great growth in year two i'm still
astounded lamar jackson was hanging
around all the way until the end of
round one a couple of years ago yeah no
no he shouldn't have been
i mean he definitely shouldn't have been
that's you know that's why i was tooting
his horn then
too he was more than just a runner he
was a guy that was wanted to throw the
football and had plenty of evidence on
film of
high level throwing was it always
perfect no but man the ravens like mike
just to capitalize or you know finish
off that thought
they got everything they really do and
not only everything like on the field
they got the right leaders the right
attitude people who love football and
love
to compete and get in the scrum and oh
it's you know it's 20
all in the fourth quarter they relish it
they really have a great makeup and yeah
they're not going anywhere we know that
um well okay i mean i gotta go
my next superlative is you know who i'm
going to i'm going up to buffalo it's my
boy blue
that's my boy i mean josh allen
yeah i mean again first off
the common theme we see here you know
you talked about
lamar we've talked about russell wilson
earlier in the show we talked about kyla
murray
now we're on josh allen here's four
quarterbacks that all had great days
passing that also led their team in
rushing
okay that just tells you these these
guys and if you want to wonder why i
have these guys ranked ahead of tom
brady and drew brees and quarterback
rankings because they can't do that crap
they can't carry their team the way they
can josh allen yesterday
was amazing and for all the people that
always want to talk about
only the negative of josh allen wow was
he accurate
man ball was on the money all day long
stop
hating on the damn kid and then his
ability to run
and create plays off of that was special
yesterday
is it a little loose still is there a
play or two you go
hey go down or don't you know
flip in the air and jump over a guy and
then fumble the football
yes he's a little crazy that way and he
still needs to be reined in but again i
think we saw just like we talked about
lamar jackson
here's another guy in year three where
we continue to see
goodness just being built on top of each
other and now with digs on that
offense and things like that josh allen
was one of the standout stars of
week one in the nfl and and look i agree
with you
and and he was one of my superlatives
under the title
don't believe what they say in august
award because he said back then he
wasn't going to run as much this year he
had 14
carries yesterday but but the first
fumble was just one of those
what in the hell houston texans moments
right that we thought would be ironed
out of his game
and there were a couple of touchdowns he
could have thrown on top of the ones he
did where the ball
sails over the the heads of the
receivers so he's still not a finished
product
no but he's getting he's getting closer
to it than he was his first two nfl
seasons exactly
to see them just blow the jets off the
field yesterday
uh a game that i for some stupid-ass
reason thought the jets would
oh oh oh oh oh oh wait wait hold on hold
on hold on
we disagreed on four games in our picks
last week
oh thy chris sims swept florio in
all four disagreements baby it's a good
week here we go
2020. yeah don't get used to it don't
get used to it
i i felt bad for you for like getting
destroyed by me so badly
against the spread i did all right
though i threaded the needle i threaded
the needle uh well no i didn't thread
the needle you
tried the needle really i think you
threaded the needle by a half point on
the bengals chargers
yeah good you picked the chargers to win
by three
and and they did which meant you got the
chargers right and you got the bengals
on the cover
yes that's what i do it's got a year
it's gonna be it's gonna be domination
i'm gonna be like mahomes now i'm gonna
throw
55 touchdown passes and 10 interceptions
just
kill you that's what i'm gonna do this
year oh i was six
seven and one versus the spread shut up
pete yeah pete
get him and get him right on the days
when pete's producing we don't get
barraged by by text messages from matt
casey on the day's case he's producing
pete's constantly chiming in
things i don't want to hear good i like
pete good i got
i got i got one more yeah matt rule is
ready for prime time award
uh overlooked and we haven't talked
about the raiders beating the panthers
you know raiders fans hey good welcome
to las vegas you went on the road and
you won but this is a game you should
have romped right this is a game
this was one of our best bets last week
raiders given three and a half and they
won by four and i don't know how the
hell they won by four
panthers gave them everything they could
handle so i mean think about all the
turmoil
we talked about the value of continuity
you've got a college coach who's got
one year as an assistant offensive line
coach in the nfl eight years
ago he's been at temple he's been at
baylor they got all these new players
all the draft picks spent on defensive
guys teddy bridgewater starting
quarterback for the first time
since the playoffs in 2015.
and they almost won the game they were
in it they were in it this is good news
for the carolina panthers
good news for matt rule this and you
know and this was a great exciting game
it was one of the best games
today but because we had it all
pigeonholed as raiders are going to
easily win
we didn't pay attention to it impressive
for the raiders
but i think more impressive for the
panthers matt rule and company are ready
to compete in the nfl
yeah they are and i think you know it
speaks to what i think a lot of people
saw in matt rule and why he's been in
that nfl
head coach conversation for the last two
or three years
yeah and then i'll tell you the other
thing he
he he took it like a man as far as his
fourth down call right where they gave
the ball to the was that the fullback up
the middle am i remember
that correctly right he he he said up
i should have given them all the
mccaffrey i should have just given the
best player like
i love that i love that the team can buy
into that
they really will they'll get behind him
they'll support him when they realize
he'll take one on the chin for them at
their expense but
there was a lot to like and that was i
mean this is a young football team in
carolina
it really is so that's very impressive
to see you know the offense made some
plays
teddy bridgewater looked good joe brady
the new offensive coordinator coming
from college he certainly seemed like he
was
not out of his league that's for sure um
yeah i mean
you're right the raiders the big thing
is a little bit like
what we talked about and i think if the
question still remains
right is one can they create some big
plays in the past game we saw a little
and then henry ruggs got hurt so that
really screwed things over that way
but then um the defense the defense is a
question i think it's going to be
continue to be a question i do you know
it's young and i just don't know how
many difference makers are on there that
can make a play to get off on third down
or a big moment in the fourth quarter
and that's going to be something to
watch out for with the raiders
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports